cela fera 20 ans demain que l'amérique a
été frappé en plein coeur par le
terrorisme on se rappelle de ces images
qui ont fait le tour du monde les tours
jumelles du world trade center touchés
par des avions détournés par des
terroristes d'al qaïda et la réponse
américaine elle ne s'est pas fait
attendre avec invasion de l'afghanistan
par les états unis vingt années de
présence dans ce pays pour traquer les
principaux responsables à des attaques
du 11 septembre
mais pour quel résultat
eh bien on en parle tout de suite avec
nos invités gérard et pierre fondateur
du webmagazine le monde décrypté us bell
fait là un consultant en relations
internationales et spécialiste du monde
arabe
bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur ft france alors le 11
septembre l'amérique est attaquée et on
a vu que quelques jours plus tard ça a
été le moment de l'arrêt poste la
riposte premier réflexe donc américain
de l'administration américaine prendre
la main le leadership du combat contre
le terrorisme le mal absolu à ce moment
là est ce qu'on peut dire déjà que la
première puissance au monde a réellement
réussi à apprendre la main ce moment là
déjà
gérard des pierres
écoutez la marque est difficile à
prendre parce que dans les premiers
jours n'est ce pas tout le monde
s'interrogeait sur quel était le groupe
qu'il était est et les responsables de
cette opération qui était vraiment deux
premiers en pleurs le monde a été
stupéfaite tout le monde se souvient où
nous étions individuellement leur
encontre septembre à 2001 donc voilà je
crois que il ya eu d'abord un promet un
moment de sidération après des
recherches rapides et effectivement une
concentration sur et bien des mouvements
terroristes djihadistes à sur
l'afghanistan mais dans un deuxième
temps dans la dans le premier moment 1
nous sommes attaqués voilà le message
qui a été donnée au président bush et
personne ne savait d'où venaient les
attaques lyonnaises belle c'est là
est-ce que selon vous justement pour
revenir à cette question les états unis
sont parvenus en tout cas à ce moment là
à prendre le leadership d'un d'une sorte
de consensus contre le terrorisme
bonsoir a battu d'abord l'attaqué du
11-septembre pour moi c'était vraiment
le l'attaquent qui a détruit en quelques
sortes l'hyper puissance des états unis
parce qu'on est arrivé à un certain
moment de dire que les états unis sont
capables de faire tout et qui sans
talent pyrale touche havel mais ça
montre est quand même que les nuits des
états unis qui était en quelque sorte
son allié en dans la gare de
l'afghanistan parce que ils ont quand
même fourni finances et soutenu les al
qaïda ont les appelons à l'époque les
combattants delà de la liberté contre
l'union soviétique et c'était quand même
aussi un moment très important qui a
marqué en quelque sorte on peut dire le
début de ce xxème siècle qui est la
guerre contre le terrorisme
maintenant depuis cette date
effectivement le terrorisme a beaucoup
évolué il n'est pas seulement un
phénomène limité à à des pays en
particulier mais ça devient aussi des
organisations transfontalière qui se
sent capable à créer de la
déstabilisation qui vise aussi le
pouvoir et c'est ça la nouvelle on va
dire de terrorisme c'est à dire que les
mouvements jihadistes ou au départ on
cherchait seulement à en quelque sorte à
faire une certaine déstabilisation à
travers l'attractivité de certains
jeunes par l'idéologie salafiste
wahhabite maintenant l'évolution c'est
que surtout à travers l'exemple ou
l'expérience de l'état islamique c'est à
dire que l'objectif de cesser de seguros
est de créer l'état l'état avec des
institutions y compris des institutions
ou un appareil sécuritaire c'est à dire
que c'était le cas par exemple de l'état
islamique en série ayant ou ayant eu en
irak y avait des ministères il y avait
des services de renseignement il y avait
aussi une capacité à faire une
communication terroriste très forte
surtout qui a profité des réseaux
sociaux et de la montée en puissance de
la de la technologie maintenant si on
peut faire un bilan on peut dire quand
même que les états unis sont échoués sur
beaucoup de 2de guerre et qui ont mené
en quelque sorte une guerre contre le
terrorisme de façon très car boutique et
en plus c'est le fait qu'ils ont aussi
lâché leur leurs alliés c'est le cas
actuellement avec les afghans c'était le
cas avec les kurdes les rebellions sait
rien un certain moment les pays les pays
du golfe donc on efface quand même à une
nouvelle on va dire politique américaine
qui vise le retrait militaire et le
désengagement pour se limiter sur le
renforcement de ses capacités at on
parlé d'échec un lyonnaise belle fête à
élire trains américains de l'afghanistan
tout on pouvoir maintenant quelques
mains des talibans justement gérard et
pierre à l'époque on se souvient que
george bush moment des attaques du 11
septembre il était très haut dans les
sondages entre temps par les déchets qui
laisse belle fait entre temps il ya eu
c'est vrai cette désillusion pour les
américains puisqu'il finalement ce
combat contre le terrorisme qui se fonde
sur des mensonges notamment l'échec de
la guerre en irak
l'invasion américaine en irak sous de
faux prétextes ya eu aussi les bavures
américaine les atteintes aux libertés
civiles avec le scandale des écoutes de
la nsa part révélé par edouard snowdon
donc tout ça finalement ça a participé
une forme de désillusion de la part
d'abord des américains leur avec pierre
vespière gérard vespier ya merci
beaucoup donc je crois qu'il faut aussi
prendre beaucoup de précautions avec ce
qui vient d'être dit précédemment et spa
à l'état islamique n'a pas été le
premier à vouloir prendre un territoire
quid des talibans en 1996
n'est ce pas donc
17 ans 18 ans 19 ans avant donc il ya
déjà eu une volonté de
gouvernement une gouverne volonté de
s'approprier un territoire a dès le
début de la base donc à al qaïda or ce
qui concerne donc l'évolution qui a pu
se faire jour depuis depuis lors fera
aussi il faut être très très très très
prudent sur le temps long parce que est
ce qu'il y avait des troupes américaines
en irak paris amp il ya maintenant n'ont
donc peut-on parler d'un retrait non
parce qu'ils sont présents maintenant
les états unis en irak est ce qu'il y a
toujours des commandos des forces
spéciales en syrie est ce qu'il y avait
des commandos des forces spéciales
américaines il
voilà on a un petit souci de liaison
avec vous gérard dhesse pierre on va
vous retrouver dans un instant mais
younès ce qu'elle fait là peut-être que
vous voulez réagir
oui j'aimerais bien juste préciser quand
même que le cas du dali bon ce sont des
afghans ce avec une idéologie islamiste
très très radicaliser mais que voulez
bien sûr le pouvoir dans le territoire
de l'afghanistan on peut pas les
comparer avec avec le projet de l'état
islamique il ya un projet du califat
c'est-à-dire qui divise le fait de faire
conquérir tous les terrains et la preuve
de cette grande transformation c'est que
avant il y avait un terrorisme qui vient
du moyen orient est principalement aussi
des pays du sud en général est là
maintenant on a un terrorisme qui menait
dans les pays
occidental donc ce qui fait que c'est à
dire en fait dans l'occident aux états
unis ou même en europe on a des réseaux
djihadistes capable de faire une
certaine déstabilisation avec des avec
des projets très radicalise et je crois
que le grand problème des des états unis
actuellement c'est quand tu n'as pas
arrivé à faire convaincre la communauté
internationale par une définition
unanime concernant la question du
terrorisme deuxièmement c'est aussi de
clarifier le ce processus qui passe de
l'islamisme à la radicalisation et de la
radicalisation à l'acte à l'acte
terroriste et troisièmement et c'est ça
le plus important c'est que le congé
parler de la question de l'échec ou du
fiasco américain c'est les résultats qui
parlent actuellement c'est à dire par
rapport à une situation héraclite est
plus ou moins stable les rats qualité
des données clés en mains à l'idée des
états unis qui est qui éliront
l'afghanistan après vingt ans de guerre
ses les talibans qui vient dans le
pouvoir et le prétexte est lui toujours
prêt pour les américains c'est cette
question de réelle politique mais réelle
politique par rapport à quel hacker
laquelle ambitions il faut penser aussi
à des drames qui se passe actuellement
en afghanistan des opérations de
vengeance le sort des femmes et des
jeunes qui sont maintenant attaqué par
ces groupes ces groupes islamistes
donc je crois que les américains ont
toujours adopté une approche
pragmatique au niveau des relations
internationales mais pendant les 20
dernières années quand même on retrouve
qu' un certain destruction de sa de la
politique de la politique étrangère
maintenant l'objectif qui a lancé ses
premiers ennemis c'est la chine gérard
espérant vous à retrouver pour
poursuivre justement il ya qu'on annule
et les quelques victoires on peut citer
la mort d'oussama ben laden en 2011 et
la mort du leader de l'état islamique
abu bakr al bagdadi quand même
tout à fait ce n'est pas simplement à
lison des victimes ou des personnes qui
ont été éliminés et comme on dit
pudiquement mais l'état islamique n'est
ce pas coupvray à plusieurs centaines de
milliers de kilomètres carrés donc il y
avait vraiment un état il y avait
vraiment une force militaire il y avait
des levée d'impôts il y avait vraiment
une organisation et c'est ça qui était
par la communauté internationale parce
que dans le cadre du combat contre
l'état islamique qui couvrait l'irak et
la syrie et il ya eu 30 pays qui ont été
impliqués a même interpol il ya des
organisations dont on fait partie de
cette organisation qui s'est confronté à
l'état islamique et donc de le
déstabiliser et ensuite pour le réduire
et donc la même chose pour al qaïda
n'est ce pas al-qaïda maintenant bon
c'est vraiment quelques groupuscules à
dans la partie sud de la péninsule
arabique
un petit peu au sahel mais ce n'est rien
par rapport à ce que ça a été il y a
vingt ans donc il y à des progrès et
comment on signalait tout à l'heure
l'afghanistan n'est ce pas qu'est ce
qu'il ya de plus beau que des femmes
dans la rue actuellement qui demandent
leur liberté
c'est ça aussi
l'activité que c'est ça aussi le
résultat de la présence non pas
seulement américaine mais occidental
dans ce pays 1 pendant bientôt vingt ans
donc il y a des désaccords conséquent
assure
wedge a géré avec pierre ont ils veulent
s p lf et n'a justement demain sont les
commémorations du 11-septembre
vingt ans après il ya eu cette débâcle
des militaires des américains dont quand
on a gagné ce temps et une majorité
d'américains
54% appui tout de même ce retrait
américain de l'afghanistan demain s
comment justement dans quel état
d'esprit vous pensez que les américains
vous commémorer cette journée du 11
septembre
battu d'abord la mort de oussama ben
laden ou doivent au parc albert l'a dit
ça veut pas dire que la fin du
terrorisme pas du tout parce qu'on a un
grand problème avec l'idéologie et en
plus les principaux on va dire allié des
états unis dans cette danse est dans
cette région sont les premiers
fournisseurs
du terrorisme le pakistan la turquie le
qatar donc c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya
plein ya plein de critiques à adresser
aux américains par rapport à l'euro
alors gestion de ceux de ce dossier du
terrorisme maintenant si on veut parler
de la puissance américaine certes qui a
maintenant d'une nouvelle puissance au
niveau mondial qui avance à travers pas
seulement la politique étrangère mais
par le biais de la diplomatie économique
je peux prendre le cas de la chine qui
représente actuellement le principal on
va dire et ennemis concurrents pour les
pour les pour les américains la question
qui s'impose c'est que mon
l'administration américain ne peut gérer
cette phase de transition tout en
gardant la domination américain sur
l'économie principalement sur la
question du dollar qui oblige les pays à
tisser des relations avec les les
américains et aussi la domination en
matière en matière technologique
maintenant la décision de retrait au
niveau de au sud de l'afghanistan où je
crois que c'est pas une décision de
l'administration
by dell des négociations avec les
talibans ont commencé avec obama on se
rappelle aussi de la fameuse photo du
pompier au ministre les affaires
étrangères de l'administration trompe
avec un des dirigeants des taliban donc
ce qui fait que c'est un c'est un
processus qui était
achevée par a parlé par les américains
l'objectif de réduire les dépenses
militaires et se focaliser sur un
redressement au niveau au niveau interne
maintenant la question qui s'impose
c'est l'avenir des alliances américaine
et principalement au niveau 2 au niveau
de l'otan c'est-à-dire l'alliance
atlantique avec des partenaires europe
gérard epiard je ne sais pas si vous
avez entendu tout à l'heure mais je
préciser qu'une majorité des américains
54% à puis quand même le retrait
américain de l'afghanistan demain jour
des commémorations du 11-septembre vingt
ans après est ce que ça peut être un
déclic pour dans l'esprit justement des
américains ces commémorations et cette
débâcle aussi en afghanistan où les
talibans sont de retour au pouvoir
bah je crois qu'il faut être prudent sur
la question de la le débat n'est ce pas
la débâcle une situation militaire
vous avez la confrontation de deux
armées qui se qui se rend compte et
l'autre qui s'enfuit à la vous avez eu
depuis dix ans et comme le rappelait un
autre autre interlocuteur ce soir à
depuis dix ans les états unis ont
méthodiquement
réduit leur présence militaire en
afghanistan il s'agit de prendre les
chiffres est là à les chiffres
on a un peu de mal justement à vous
entendre gérard vespière est ce que vous
nous entendez
non on va conclure avec vous et younes
el fellah très rapidement
moi je crois qui est qu'on passe par une
phase de transition
l'administration américaine est obligé
maintenant de présenter plein de
concessions politiques et surtout
d'allégeance par rapport à certaines à
certains à certains puissance mais ça
peut pas dire que la sphère du tourisme
est terminée ou au contraire on est on
est face à une évolution dont tout l'est
dans tous les niveaux politique et
biologique et technologiques du
terrorisme au niveau au niveau mondial
et donc ce qui se passe actuellement
montrent clairement l'affaiblissement
des institutions internationales parce
qu'on parle des des états unis des pays
de l'europe mais en parle pas la science
d'une huile le rôle de ces institutions
qui sont créés pendant le xxème siècle
et qui n'arrivent plus à gérer les défis
et les enjeux du 21e siècle vous
concluez rapidement gérard vesper
puisqu'on a rétabli la liaison avec vous
et
écoutez je pense qu'effectivement on
n'imaginait pas il ya 20 ans ce qui
pouvait se passer dans les heures et
dans les jours qui viennent à kipré qui
allait suivre donc le 11 septembre 2001
on s'attendait à un feu nucléaire
possible enfin tout était envisageable
la première puissance américaine et donc
mondiale été attaqué à 20 ans plus tard
les états unis sont toujours
effectivement en en tête de course même
si effectivement la chine est maintenant
un partenaire et un adversaire plus
exactement
redoutable mais la puissance militaire
reste dans l'espace dans l'aviation dans
la marine on se porte avions donc là la
puissance économique militaire
stratégique américaine est toujours là
mais les écarts se sont réduits à avec
les poursuivants si je puis dire et donc
nous avons là une situation nouvelle
pour les années 2020 2030 si beaucoup
avoue gérard vespière fondateurs du web
magazine le monde décrypté on a eu des
petits soucis techniques avec vous mais
on vous a bien entendu finalement merci
à vous également younès rebelles sheila
consultant en relations internationales
spécialiste du monde arabe